[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d'attali
d'interdire je reçois ariane nicolas
pour son essai l'imposture antispécistes
nadeah et béquilles qui sortent leur
premier disque dream beach ça veut dire
[ __ ] de rêve sur le traduit en
français vincent ravalec que pour la fin
des haricots le troisième et dernier
volume de sa saga sainte-croix des
vaches qui mélange avec humour 3
obsession de notre époque la ruralité le
trafic de drogue et l'elysée et martine
de l'élève pour le salon des artistes
français au grand palais c'est la 230e
édition et l'on commence tout de suite
par notre époque qu'est ce qui la
caractérise
voici les réponses en images et la
première image c'est la vôtre nadery
béquilles oui pourquoi cette image
évidemment parce que on peut être dans
une situation très concrète et réelle
alors qu'on n'ait rien aux gens combien
your d'enseigner dans ses dons ses
lunettes en l'occurrence ceux des
lunettes de réalité virtuelle vous
l'avez déjà essayé non becky de
l'univers c'est nadia qui travaillent
qui traduira béquille qui est anglo
syrienne votre image avoue vincent
ravalec c'est celle ci c'est bien aussi
moi j'ai trouvé cette image intéressante
parce que y'a rien naturelle là dedans
tout est fabriqué en voit même plus
l'homme donc je trouve qu'elle pose la
question qu'est ce qu'on va faire après
peut-être rien peut-être rien mais bon
il ya tout de même un petit futur on
peut décoller vers la lune au moins que
tu es très loin en tout cas c'est ce que
ça induit tout en faisant nos courses et
je trouve que cette image elle est à la
fois empreinte de empreinte de toute
notre histoire est à la fois empreinte
de paradoxe est que ces paradoxes qu'il
faut résoudre comme il faut tout de même
se projeter un peu dans le futur c'est
pour ça que je les choisis martin de la
lf oui alors qu'ici
est une c'est la verrière du grand
palais où se tient actuellement le sien
actuellement le salon la 230e édition de
notre salon et cette image symbolise à
la fois là la luxuriance de dollars mais
aussi la permanence de cette énergie qui
traverse le temps il
le salon des artistes français est là
depuis 1901 à peu près exactement deux
sous la verrière du grand palais depuis
oui tous les murs existants avant au
louvre etc
mais depuis dix ans a donc c'est cette
image symbolise pour moi actuellement la
permanence du dollar cette énergie qui
traverse le temps alors sauf que l'année
prochaine vous n'y serez plus parce
qu'elle est très beau oui mais nous nous
existeront toujours
et puis il ya déjà eu des travaux et
vous êtes ça c'est l'image de tard ian
nicholas alors que cris beau jake
hoffman qui vient de finir c'est un
petit clin d'oeil à l'antispécisme
puisque c'est une série où les
personnages sont tous avec décors du mam
avec des têtes d'animaux ou du maroc une
espèce de grand mélange qui se fait est
ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est le
dédoublement de personnalité en fait que
ça laisse entendre à savoir que le beau
jake qui est bien habillé qui à
l'extérieur c'est un peu la version
idéale du vrai beau jake qui est
peut-être même en train de se noyer peut
qu'il est en train de nager qu'est ce
que je peux a beau jake un beau jake
hoffman c'est donc le personnage est en
fait ce que j'aime bien c'est cette
image là qui à mon avis est très
prégnante aujourd'hui les réseaux
sociaux qui est qu'en fait on a un mot
idéal qu'on projette et qui finit par
nous tyranniser qui est en permanence en
train de nous regarder
alors que nous on est peut-être on vaut
peut-être pas mieux que d'être sur la
chine est bien commençons
[Musique]
ariane nicolas vous êtes journaliste
vous publiez l'imposture antispécistes
chez des clés de bruère vous
reconnaissez que qu'en refusant de
placer l'humain au centre le mouvement
le au centre de son système j'entends le
mouvement antispéciste constituer un
défi totalement inédit pour la
philosophie et c'est vrai que c'est
aujourd'hui le mouvement d'idées sans
doute le plus original et le plus
puissant de ce début de 21e siècle c'est
peut-être justement la raison pour
laquelle il attire autant de gens c'est
que c'est un mouvement qui est nouveau
et qui apporte quelque sorte d'air frais
disons dans les réflexions sur la
politique etc et sur l'environnement
notamment l'ours est maintenant rentré
dans le dictionnaire antispécistes mais
vous avez quand même nous redéfinir de
quoi il s'agit exactement
merci quand est-ce qu'on sp6 ou anti
spécial or justement le dictionnaire
l'édition ne sont pas d'accord dans la
mesure où pour les antispécistes c'est
nous qui sommes spéciste c'est à dire
que l'idéologie c'est le spécisme c'est
à dire une discrimination qui viserait
les animaux de la part des humains je
pense qu'il faut prendre les choses à
l'envers il faut considérer plutôt que
l'idéologie c'est l'antispécisme c'est à
dire cette façon de considérer qu'il
n'ya pas de distinction moral entre les
humains et les animaux et que du coup
les animaux devraient être inclus dans
une serre politique absolument élargie
et donc bénéficier de droits
particuliers comme ne pas souffrir ne
pas être enfermé ne pas être tués ne pas
être exquis qui constitue une véritable
révolution intellectuelle
exactement c'est très différent de
l'écologie qui est évidemment quelque
chose qui est très très long
l'antispécisme savenay disons dans les
années soixante dix avec le philosophe
australien qui s'appelle peter singer
qui écrit la libération animale et qui a
un petit peu la bible en fait de toutes
ces personnes qui ont donné lieu en fait
enfin le les livres ont donné lieu au
mode de vie vegan ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que l'antispécisme
c'est la version politisé militante
intransigeante on peut même dire
intolérante d'un mode de vie vegan
auquel tout le monde a droit évidemment
si on refuse de manger des oeufs du lait
du fromage
moi ça me regarde pas ça ne regarde les
organes sont différents des végétariens
dans le sens où non seulement ils ne
mangent d'aucun animaux mais en plus ils
ne veulent pas porter des chaussures
prada tu as écrit ali a par exemple du
cuir des animaux un porte pas de
maquillage dans lequel il ya des
expérimentations à goma
elle etc c'est vraiment une révolution
et c'est aussi une révolution qui passe
par le fait de se révolutionner soi-même
commence avec soin et ensuite après
l'idée c'est de changer la société c'est
pour ça qu'ils anticipaient 6 sont des
militants qui font des actions qui
peuvent être parfois assez violente et
des agressions de bouche et de
charcutiers etc
et vous si mal quand même il y en a il
ya eu mille actions antispécistes en
2019 qui a été qu'ils ont été
répertoriés par les gendarmes sa vie
surtout en fait les agriculteurs
maintenant c'est à dire des inscriptions
des tags un peu dégradations de matériel
et surtout c'est un phénomène qui est
très nouveau et qui bénéficie d'une
forme de bienveillance de la part des
médias qui fait que les gens qui en sont
et ce qu'ils sont visés se sentent un
peu démunis se sentent délaissés par le
pouvoir politique
alors depuis le début du 20e siècle on
abolit à peu près toutes les hiérarchies
toutes les frontières que l'on avait
dressé jusque là entre alors par exemple
entre les blancs et le reste de
l'humanité entre les hommes et les
femmes entre les adultes et les enfants
entre les hommes les hétérosexuels et
les homosexuels il est à peu près
logique qu'aujourd'hui ça touche le
reste du vivant surtout avec la crise
environnementale et forcément les
animaux c'est les suivants et justement
la question c'est de savoir pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils devraient y rester une
frontière on va dire anthologique très
forte entre les humains et les animaux
vous parliez des noirs des blancs des
femmes des hommes tout ça ça reste
exactement la même humanité et le
problème c'est que ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas ça n'a pas toujours été là
est le problème c'est que les lumières
par exemple qui sont vraiment sereine
ion qui célèbre la raison se sont
trompés sur certains sujets le problème
c'est qu'ils auraient dû accorder des
droits aux femmes aux minorités et aux
trans et c'est aussi alors qu'ils ne
l'ont pas fait et du coup aujourd'hui en
fait on est en train de faire plutôt une
sorte de de révision de cette pensée
politique qui était inachevée mais qui
doit s'arrêter quelque part et la raison
à mon avis pour laquelle elle doit
s'arrêter à l'humanité c'est que la
sensibilité qui est le critère disons
paradigm sur lequel s'appuient les
antispécistes n'est pas suffisant pour
justifier d'avoir des droits soit parce
qu'on peut souffrir ou avoir du plaisir
qu'on doit avoir des droits
supplémentaires et pourtant c'est
vraiment eu la limite qui le qu'il trace
et je pense que un droit ne doit pas
dépendre de ce seul critère là peut
dépendre de absolument autre chose et ce
serait quoi la raison la conscience la
régionale il ya alors le propre de
l'humain est en fait on a des centaines
yade est propre de l'humain la raison la
conscience l'art vous avez aussi la
métaphysique la peur de la mort enfin
évidemment que les animaux reste disons
dans un dans des mondes
ils ont plusieurs mondes chaque animal a
son nom à dire mais qui sont quand même
très différentes des nôtres
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
de rappeler qu'un droit ça vient d'une
communauté qui ces assemblées d'une
société qui a décidé de vivre ensemble
et que c'est à partir de là que les
droits sont créés c'est très compliqué
parce que quand on voit cette photo
comme n'importe laquelle de celles qu'on
va voir on se dit que cet animal non
seulement évidemment éprouve de la
douleur est sensible il a peur de la
mort
il a des petits il a une femelle etc etc
il est très difficile de se dire au nom
de quoi est ce qu'on le priverait de sa
femelle de ces petits au nom de quoi est
ce qu'on le ferait danser comme ont fait
danser les ours
au nom de quoi est ce que on peut le
tuer s'il à l'envi nous en prend etc etc
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai problème et
c'est très difficile de répondre aux
antispécistes faisait beaucoup de
courage et d'abnégation d'avoir voulu le
faire tout au long d'un livre je pense
que là là des images que vous mettez
donc l'ours et le tigre montre bien
qu'il ya quand même différente façon
d'aborder l'animalité c'est à dire que
je pense qu'il faut conserver l'idée que
les animaux sauvages sont faits pour
être des animaux sauvages mais moi en
étant absolument pas antispécistes je
considère que les eaux avec les animaux
et quelque chose d'une aberration
ça n'est pas tout à la fois de votre
livre mais les eaux c'est ce qui permet
aussi de les protéger les derniers alors
voilà justement façon dont l'idée a fat
joe ya plus paix il ya plus d'une année
on peut avoir des centres qui seraient
des centres d'accueil pour la
reproduction pour les sourires de
l'espèce qui doivent être à mon avis
encourager mais l'idée d'en faire un
théâtre d'en faire un spectacle
je pense que là on a un peu dépassé
ce n'est pas normal que les enfants
aient envie de voir bellion et si tout
est fait maison parce que les seuls les
riches pourraient aller les voir en
afrique et pas les pauvres il est très
possible que nos modes de vie changeront
dans les décennies à venir on prendra
moins l'avion on verra moins de lyon il
va peut-être falloir se se protéger se
préparer à avoir des choses qui changent
on verra des lions peut-être peut-être
en réalité virtuelle qui s'est en tout
cas dans les livres d'image ou dans les
films c'est toujours faire des
documentaires sur eux ces dons jamais vu
de lyon et je me sens pas discriminer d
en citer ce qui est drôle c'est qu'à la
fois les les antispécistes sont bien
obligés de constater que si on faisait
tout ce qu'ils nous disent il n'y aurait
quasiment plus d'animaux parce que bien
entendu on ne continuera pas de faire
vivre des millions d'animaux
alors qu'on ne les mangent plus qu'on ne
les exploitent plus donc y aura
quasiment plus d'animaux ils s'en font
une raison et vous aussi vous faites une
raison à l'idée qu'on ne verra plus lyon
et c'est pas grave on prendra pas
l'avion n'y aura pas deux eaux et puis
nous enfermerons patients que c'est pas
grave c'est que ça s'aggrave d'accord ni
antispécistes sp6 je fais il faut que je
vois des lions mais aussi mes vaches et
notamment justement la question à mon
avis qui est central dans l'antre
spécisme c'est plutôt celle de l'élevage
ce qu'ils veulent faire disparaître ce
sont tous les animaux d'élevage
ils considèrent comme étant il
légitimement à propriété des humains
élevage ça fait peu après dix mille ans
que ça existe et on sait sédentarité
sont sédentarisés grâce à l'élevage
on ad'abord domestiques et les plantes
vous le rappelez quand même après on a
domestiqué les animaux et l'idée c'est
que justement ces animaux qui n'ont pour
le coup d'éclat des conditions de vie
qui sont sans doute assez assez
difficile voire atroce mais adapté au
nombre que nous sommes sur terre
aujourd'hui adapté de reconnaître qu'il
ya autant de poulets doigt dans les
batteries c'est parce qu'on est à là on
est 8 milliards l'option c'est soit on
mange moins de viande
moi je propose par exemple moi
vous la viande plusieurs fois par jour
plusieurs repas je me suis j'essaye de
me me dire que notamment pour des
raisons écologiques d'environnement il
faut réduire vraiment la consommation de
viande et j'essaie de dire un repas
végétarien par jour une on mange de la
viande une fois par jour comme ça mon
avis c'est très simple à retenir
mais le problème c'est que soit on fait
ça mais des gens qui ont dit revenons
c'est encore trop dans ce cas là ce
qu'il faut c'est dans l'autre côté c'est
de l'option malthusienne c'est réduire
la population et moi je trouve ça
absolument scandaleux de dire la seule
alternative à l'élevage c'est de faire
moins d'enfants ça je peux pas entendre
mais revenons aux ailes à cette
révolution antispécistes que vous
qualifiez da posture ariani que là les
antispécistes dit vous voit des
impératifs de justice là où en réalité
n'émerge que des considérations morales
sans fondement la morale c'est ce qu'il
dit voilà il est jeune il faut pas lui
faire de mal
ils estiment que le fait qu'il s'agit
ferait mal c'est injuste de faire
souffrir
vous dites c'est pas une question de
c'est pas la question
alors c'est quoi la question c'est pas
une question de justice dans le sens
encore une fois la justice est là pour
notamment redistribuer des biens faire
partager des richesses etc
la question morale c'est plutôt un
rapport éthique même plutôt à l'animal
la question c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'a pas le droit de tuer les animaux
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas le
droit de tuer les animaux
il ya un philosophe emmanuel levinas qui
explique très bien qu' il ya une
spécificité humaine dans leur rapport à
l'autre lui par deux visages il dit.le
l'autre en fait par son visage me montre
sa vulnérabilité et j'en suis
responsable automatiquement un aspect
phénoménologique c'est à dire le fait
simple fait de voir un humain me dit non
me donne un interdit
et aujourd'hui les antispécistes parle
par exemple de meurtre alimentaire et ça
c'est une expression contre laquelle moi
j'ai vraiment envie de me battre parce
qu'on ne tue un animal ce n'est pas la
même chose que tu as un être humain et
il parle de viol pour l'insémination
artificielle des vaches avec une forme
de l'anthropomorphisme comme ça qui me
semble assez assez coupable en fait
assez dangereuse et même violente
dir et pourquoi est ce qu'on ne peut pas
commettre un meurtre sur un animal c'est
qu'au fond on ne commet un meurtre que
lorsqu'il ya une vraie transgression il
ya une transgression quand je tue mon
prochain
quand je tue quelqu'un qui peut me
ressemble et qui pourrait être mon frère
qui pourrait être mon père mes parents
quelqu'un sur ce plateau
là il ya une vraie transgression à
partir du moment où c'est tout un
écosystème qui est créé sur le fait
d'avoir des prédateurs je veux dire
c'est la nature on n'a pas décidé
il n'y a pas de transgression de ce côté
là mais en moyenne me semble-t-il une
transgression quand même c'est que la
plupart d'entre nous même si nous
mangeons de la viande et nous mangeons
des animaux nous sommes incapables de
les tuer nous sommes incapables de les
tuer parce qu'on en a pas la nécessité
d'autres s'en chargent pour nous mais
parce que on serait propre banc
incapable de le faire
si à la place de vous a posé un repas
végétarien par par semaine vous imposiez
de tuer les animaux que vous mangez vous
en auriez beaucoup moins c'est très
sympa et la réponse à ça c'est que je
pense que la question végétarienne elle
est quand même spécifique vraiment si je
pense que c'est plus difficile de
répondre à la question justement du fait
de tuer des animaux que du fait de les
élever les vegan ils ne sont pas
seulement sur la question de ne pas
manger des animaux c'est une question
est le végétarisme c'est une question
qui est vieille comme l'antiquité et des
philosophes qui disent déjà l'antiquité
mais si vous voulez tuer les animaux
vous même et puis on verra ce que vous
en ferez ce qui montre que les airs que
les humains ne sont pas des animaux
vraiment comme tout le monde c'est à
dire qu'au fond on n'arrive pas à tuer
d'autres animaux on n'arrive plus en
tout cas à le faire mais leur revanche
récolté des oeufs devenir apiculteur
traire une vache ça c'est des choses
qu'on peut absolument tous faire et qui
me semble presque relever du bon sens en
fait les antispécistes père un
changement de perspective 10 bout en
faisant basculer la question du
bien-être animal qui nous occupe depuis
beaucoup plus longtemps qu'on le croit
la spa été créés au 19e siècle
c'est parce qu'on voulait plus voir
souffrir les animaux en tout cas pas sur
la voie publique
donc le bien être animal on y pense
depuis très très longtemps mais ils font
basculer la question du bien-être animal
vers la libération l'émancipation où
l'égalité est en fait ils en font une
question politique est là c'est assez
décontenançant pour les pour
l'expressiste on va les appeler parce
que personne n'a jamais réfléchi à ça au
nom de quoi
ces animaux là ne pourrait pas avoir une
représentation comment non les enfants
par exemple que sont représentés par
leurs parents l'intérêt de l'enfant est
prise en compte par la société comme
l'intérêt des handicapés mentaux de
toutes sortes de populations comme ça
qui ne votent pas qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément de conscience politique
néanmoins qui existe sur l'échiquier et
quand on dit pourquoi pas les animaux
c'est difficile de répondre à ça mais il
ya une représentation animale qui existe
des associations qui se bat énormément
choses déjà qu'ils sont interdites dans
les comportements qu'on a avec les
animaux la différence c'est à dire qu'au
19e siècle
on était plutôt là pour réprimer les
comportements cruelle des humains et que
en reconnaissant depuis deux ans les
animaux comme des êtres sensibles dans
le droit c'est vrai qu'il ya un
changement de perspective
oui mais qui est totalement illusoire on
réalise est déjà là et saad hariri
s'était déjà là et ça me changera
renâcle auxquels on fait allusion qu'on
a changé entre guillemets c'est juste
qui permette pour les humains d'être
propriétaire des animaux
c'est ce qu'on appelle ça un objet c'est
bien une objets meubles voilà 70 coups
sûrs d'être propriétaire mais la
question c'est de savoir aussi à
l'avenir qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir
avoir comme droits supplémentaires par
rapport aux animaux et je pense que ce
que vous disiez par exemple par rapport
aux eaux par rapport au cirque
ça va faire partie des choses où il va y
avoir des associations qui vont se faire
entendre des partis politiques qui vont
aussi je pense vraiment rentrer dans
l'arène politique on voit que par
exemple aux européennes le parti
animalistes
sa première élection a fait plus de 2 %
c'est plus que le pcfc plus que lui d y
sent qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose qui
a changé et je pense que ce qui explique
aussi cette prégnance et cette prise de
l'antispécisme dans l'opinion c'est le
fait qu'en fait les politiques ne font
presque rien ça fait des décennies qu'il
y à des militants brigitte bardot
évidemment mais beaucoup d'autres
marguerite yourcenar qui dit je digère
mal l'agonie à propos pour justifier son
rejet taris mme les politiques ont
vraiment fait très très peu de choses
il ya deux ans il ya une loi qui devait
passer la loi agriculture alimentation
pourra interdire le fait de broyer des
poussins vivant etc
c'est même pas passé donc en fait on se
dit il ya des espèces de blocage qui
sont absolument considérable et plus les
politiques bloc et plus les militants ou
envie je pense en fait se radicalise et
vont défendre des choses qui n'aura
peut-être pas défendu si l'agriculture
extensive comme ça n'avait pas existé si
on était resté sur des modèles à taille
humaine avec un respect de l'animal avec
une vraie relation en fait qui se passe
entre les humains et des animaux
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on n'en serait
pas là bas soit ravalec ça pourrait être
un sujet de roman pour vous le mets
l'anticipation un sujet de roman mais
c'est un sujet de réflexion depuis très
longtemps parce que moi je me suis
beaucoup intéressé à moi je mange pas de
viande depuis 30 ans pas vraiment pour
des raisons de respect de l'animal mais
un peu pour tout un tas de raisons mais
cette idée du respect de la vie qui
apparaît par exemple fondamental dans le
canton s'intéresse au bouddhisme mais en
fait ça n'a quasiment pas de sens vous
marchez sur un petit bout de gazon vous
écrabouillé je ne sais pas combien de
fourmies vous touchez vous combien
d'acariens là viennent de mourir dans
une agonie probablement aux rimes et ça
ne s'arrête pas aux animaux parce qu'on
sait maintenant que les végétaux ou une
proprioception dans ce canton
h comme ça un champ de blé ou qu'on
croque une radis jrc et dire quelle
peine ont fait quelle souffrance on
provoque enfin c'est une question
absolument un soleil jeudi on est placé
au milieu d'un monde où la prédation et
ce qui ce qui nous fonde un jus dire
sans prédation géré le monde
est ce que vous dites sur le la
sédentarisation et l'agriculture était
tout à fait juste donc que faire c'est
une question que je n'arrive je n'ai
jamais réussi à résoudre à shahukhel
les antispécistes n'ont pas résolu
encore le problème non plus de savoir si
on nous interdit à nous tous êtres
humains de tuer des animaux
est-ce qu'on interdira aux animaux de se
tuent entre eux il ya des pour et des
contres mais il y en a certains qui
disent bah oui il faut empêcher les
animaux de se tuer entre eux c'était là
on est dans un des quelque chose d'anti
naturel un point mais après tout nous
aussi on s'est empêché de nous tue de se
tuer dans un des autres pourquoi une
personne empêcher des animaux c'est une
vraie question est je sur la fin nous
disons que je pense que pour le coup ça
déséquilibrerait absolument l'homme à
l'animal et [ __ ] seigneur d'ailleurs
dit ce serait pas mal mais on pour des
raisons pratiques peut-être qu'il faut
pas trop aller dessus parce qu'en fait
on n'y arrive pas donc on voit que d'un
point de vue vision pragmatique c'est un
faisable et puis et puis je pense aussi
que effectivement en fait on a n'a
jamais fini parce que c'est une sorte
d'obsession pour la souffrance qui fait
que peut-être ce qu'il faut arriver à
accepter c'est que la souffrance à elle
fait aussi partie de la vie et la
souffrance
elle est là il faut arriver à ne pas
trop souffrir et mais ne pas souffrir du
tout je trouve que c'est aussi quelque
chose qui peut être extrêmement
angoissant en fait imaginer que nous on
soit tous là et qu'on ait aucune
sensibilité qu'on sur des espèces de
machines qui ne qui ne ressent que
jamais de tristesse de douleurs de deuil
et c est ce que la ville voudrait
vraiment le coup d'être vécue mais je
n'en suis pas sûr néanmoins si on se
disait constamment qu'on risque d'être
mangé je suis pas sûr que la vigueur
c'est très excitant pour autant et
effectivement mais le fait de ne plus
avoir de prédateurs naturels c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qui met en
question notre statut hégémonique c'est
à dire qu'on est les seuls êtres
aujourd'hui qui ne risquons pas de se
faire tuer par le monde animal et c'est
peut-être là qu'il ya une forme
d'injustice madea vous êtes australienne
comme peter ring girls le
le penseur de l'antispécisme vous êtes
vous-même vegan anticipé si je pense que
oui parce que sinon je le suis depuis un
mois de l'essence et j'ai eu des
périodes où j'étais fait chuter rennes
total elle et elle est quasiment fait
chuter rien aux six mois j'ai fait
pareil en lisant ce livre il
il a donné plusieurs modifications se
lever du tarissement par exemple il ya
des gens qui se permettent de la manger
deux fois par an il ya des d'autres
systèmes moi par exemple parce que je
n'ai tellement gens avec mes
spécifications diététique
quand je vais chez quelqu'un je fais pas
je fais pas de problème pour eux mais
j'ai vite chez moi je peux pas manger
décrochant parce que je le trouve très
intelligent on a tous les systèmes
mais chacun est mis la barre quelque
part ouais mais nous on en chanson là
dessus seul pays qui se fait l'idiot
teinte et le caractère qui le chante
élèves est élève égal mais alors envie
de tuer tous les former dans sa maison
parce que ça lui gêne donc quand on joue
dans le même si tu as un peu plus léger
mais en tout sept sujets aussi vous vous
dites oh faut vous succédez
l'antispécisme de faire le lit du
transhumanisme édito au fond
l'antispécisme à nous rendre dépendants
des machines plus dépendants des
machines que des animaux c'est un os 30
centrisme pas un humanisme sous nous
serons tous des animaux non humains au
lieu de hisser les animaux à notre
niveau du main on risque nou 2-2 de nous
considérer de nous traiter nous mêmes
comme des animaux donc en fait c'est le
transhumanisme qui va l'emporter
c'est plus une hypothèse là pour le coup
puisque transhumanisme on sait pas
exactement comment les choses vont
évoluer
mais c'est vrai que si on considère que
les animaux sont doivent faire une
espèce de séparatisme on va les
remplacer par des robots
ça c'est déjà fait avec les bleus
et les chevaux traits qui ont été
remplacés par exemple qui plus est qui
n'existe plus vraiment effectivement
mais c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose
qui risque d'arriver
l'idée que si on reste aussi nombreux et
qu'on doit tous devenir végétarien ou
vegan la terre devra être absolument
exploiter par des végétaux par des
légumes et il faudra forcément sans
doute que ce qui arrive déjà que
l'intelligence artificielle aide à
répartir les denrées et puis il ya la
viande artificielle qui commencent déjà
à arriver en laboratoire et qui peut
alors on sait pas exactement encore une
fois dans quelle mesure ça pourrait être
comestible mais en tout cas et des
recherches qui sont faites dans ce sens
il est parrain possible que d'ici
quarante ou cinquante ans ce soir un
substitut et que les gens disent bah oui
mais est ce que tu es une vache
bon j'ai une cuisse de poulet qui a été
créé en laboratoire dans c'est déjà dans
les restaurants vegan on peut manger des
burgers de soja etc
il ya une imitation délà des plats
traditionnel une limitation à la fois
sur la forme mais sur le bout oui et des
hot dogs avec des saucisses qui sont
faites à base de carros ce qui montre
bien qu'il ya peut-être une nostalgie
disons dans certains modes de vie et
puis même en termes de goût je pense que
la viande a un goût absolument
particulier et la grèce est quelque
chose pour le coup qui donne vraiment dû
fumer et la grèce c'est quelque chose
que les gens ont commencé à faire que
les australopithèques consommer que
sapiens à consommer depuis le début qui
était vraiment ce qui donnait de
l'énergie et tous rapports comme ça à la
chair et os gras pose aussi la question
de est ce que c'est vraiment au fond une
idéologie très politique
ou est-ce que derrière il ya pas quand
même dans là toute la complexité des
affects qui font que les gens se
tournent vers une écologie quelque chose
aussi qui est lié à une gastronomie est
en fait peut-être au fait de pour
certaines personnes de vouloir maigrir
plus facilement
disons que c'est c'est des choses qui
sont aussi à mon avis complexe a pas une
seule raison pour lesquelles les gens
deviennent antispécistes ya différents
facteurs et peut-être que voilà la
posture antispécistes ça vient de
paraître aux éditions desclée de brouwer
ont fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
il faut bien comprendre que les champs
de schiste pétroliers américains donc
quelques temps vont s'arrêter de
produire violer toutes les données
pétrolières sont confidentielles
est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'à terme
avec le pétrole de schiste les
américains soient énergétique
indépendant banon ils sont en train de
frôler indépendance mais pour le pour le
gars cylisme en mai pour le pétrole
non c'est puis là le puits de gist sont
des puits qui donne le maximum
les premiers mois après c'est une chute
continuelle
si les pétroles de schiste des cent
cette année suffisamment pour que ça
soit notable en moins devant brême ne
sera pas relayée
[Musique]
je
à
oui
[Musique]
il faudrait que les nations puissent se
regrouper notamment une troisième force
et c'est troisième force et l'europe
mais l'europe est incapable de faire ça
il y à une remise en cause de la
relation très privilégiée entre l'europe
et les étals et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
nous devrions développer un dialogue
france allemagne russie chez tous
absents ça ça parait pas avancer dans le
bon sens quand même le risque pour nous
c'est de sortir de l'histoire
moi je suis convaincu que l'avenir des
relations internationales pour les 15
ans qu'il est c'est la relation entre
les etats-unis et la chine nous
européens si nous ne sommes pas capables
d'être troisième pole à ce moment là on
aura des fragilités et en sortira
d'histoire
[Musique]
mes invités sont aujourd'hui ariane
nicolas pour l'imposture antispécistes
vincent ravalec pour la fin des haricots
le troisième et dernier volume de sa
saga sainte-croix des vaches martin de
la love pour la 230e édition du salon
des artistes français au grand palais et
nadia et béquilles qui sortent leur
premier ep dreams byd chez eux est-ce
que [ __ ] de rêve vous paraît une bonne
traduction
ouais ouais ça se voit pas je me suis
dit xavier jei penser mais je
préférerais que ce soit pas ce soit pas
eu non seulement mon interprétation
alors on va voir tout de suite votre
interprétation à vous de du concept
sable de rêve c'est le clip qui a
réalisé béquille kombucha qu'est ce que
ces combis cha départ comme boisson de
santé qui est un peu glorifié par les
médias dans les milieux bobo acquis qui
a des bactéries des microbes est
bénéfique pour la digestion et tout ça
mais les si on fait un peu de recherche
les quantités dedans c'est très peu par
rapport à nos besoins
à combien on vous écoute une boucle
[Musique]
des blindés 9,8 depuis la famille
d'avoir chimie de belley toi tu aimes ça
tu es second souffle aux horaires de
tuyaux
[Musique]
chaque automne pour sotchi mais qui
plaisent aux jo
comme ça
qui sait
[Musique]
m
obama fait encore
alors
[Musique]
m
et à sa fille
[Musique]
m
mais pas que
oui
[Musique]
on est des amis ronda et australienne
d'origine indienne et serbes
il paraît que c'est resté en france
parce que vous aviez perdu votre
passeport c'est vrai c'est vrai madonna
passe pas d'accord vous êtes française
maintenant le début c'était vraiment
pour ça y est vous avez commencé par
chanter dans le métro - ouais ouais j'ai
commencé à 18 ans j'ai joué au papa dans
le métro dans le devon les bah ouais
celle là bas du marché où j'ai rencontré
en français on a craint on a créé un
groupe ensemble c'est comme ça que je
reste et vous b qui m'arrive vous êtes
anglo syrienne voilà et vous vous êtes
surtout réalisatrice en fait plus que
chanteuse 9,8 au mitan oui et vous êtes
rencontrés comment toutes les deux en
fait pas la fête qu'est la réalisatrice
moi je chercherai les actrices pour mon
projet j'ai rencontré et tout d'un coup
je me suis dit à l'autre projet que je
fais là ça pourrait être bien sa voix
parce qu elle est anglaise et les
caractères que j'avais créé jeudi
ça va être trop bien y aller chanter
deux chansons est déchiré je lui dis ah
il faut qu'on fasse un coup quoi et et
l'idée c'était dream beach c'était ça le
rêve l'idée le concept en fait en fait
ça c'est toujours un deuxième degré nous
notre optique c'est le spontanéité c'est
seul frivolité elle et irrévérence total
mais aux sujets qui sont très importants
comme par exemple sa combi tu sais ce
consumérisme c'est nous qui suit
n'importe quel schéma n'importe quel
nutritionniste que nous donne on le suit
sans faire un bon vrai chercheur ou une
autre société s est pas chaque personne
donc même si on approche les sujets
importants
en fait avec manière très légère et
alors il ya une chanson que j'aime
beaucoup c'est où es tu t'en française
et or là c'est quoi le le sens caché le
sens c'est comme un but dans la faute de
nicolas bary sait où es tu en ce moment
parce que je vois par exemple hier soir
j'ai regardé par la fenêtre tout le
monde dans le téléphone quand je
rencontre quelqu'un est ce que tu t'es
sur ma joue pas ce qu'était avec mes
yeux est ce qu était avec tes enfants
que tu dois chercher à l'école je sais
pas mais le fait qu'il ya manque de
présence qui est amplifié par la fête
quand on a les téléphones qui on
pourrait rester dans 24 24 c'est ce
sujet là alors y'a pas de clip on va
l'écouter vous allez l'interpréter en
playback puisqu'ici on a des effets
vidéo quand peu sur les chansons on
écoute tout de suite où es tu
monsieur
[Musique]
sur les os
il ya un troisième personnage dans votre
duo c'est nicolas c'est marc collin du
groupe troisième vague auquel vous avez
appartenu au programme bach a beaucoup
de succès en france et c'est lui qui a
composé les chansons avec vous parfois
oui parfois en fait il est il est
producteur
donc c'est à dire on peut venir avec les
concepts jeudi une troisième bague passé
nouvelle vague de produits
oui donc en ont créé ensemble parfois
c'est la musique qui donne 100 sessions
dédiées décrit quelque chose mais très
souvent nous quand on est dans la rue et
tout ça en août
un concept à prendre dix ans vas-y on va
se lancer là dedans et on peut créer
tout seul mais lui il est tellement fort
et tellement vite
il a un style particulier qui va super
bien avec notre
l'idée qu'on voulait faire que c'était
un truc s'obtenait qui est un truc
minima comme minimaliste électro punk et
lui il est vraiment la personne fort
pour ça le plus pop que cesser de 6 à la
tenue de quelqu'un disait tout à l'heure
c'est bien dans le métro est ce que
c'est un projet sérieux pour vous parce
que vous n'avez pas l'air de le dette de
vous prendre au sérieux quand vous
l'interprétez mais est ce que pour
autant c'est un projet sérieux
aujourd'hui on fait tellement de projets
dans les musiques aux amendes si c'est
toujours sérieux non à millas et arias
quand on se prend pas sérieusement parce
qu'on trouve ya beaucoup de choses
données au monde qui est très sérieux
très lourd ce qui est génial acquis
important et tout à sa place mais moi je
trouverons peut on veut essayer de
creuser un trou coup c'est léger mais le
contenu est forte quand même que c'est
pas enchanté n'importe quoi parce que
c'est drôle evrard a vraiment rien du
tout derrière mais la manière qu'on le
porte c'est un truc qui est drôle qui
est un peu amusant est ce que vous allez
faire de l'asean bientôt oui entre les
scènes
on va faire le sortie ça va être un
loupé à paris celle ci c'est le 5 mars
on va jouer là il ya un truc qui se perd
un festival qui s'appelle les femmes
s'en mêlent on va jouer le 26 mars à à
paris aussi va des béquilles le premier
rhdp ça s'appelle dream bitches
[Musique]
vincent ravalec le troisième et dernier
volume de votre saga sainte-croix des
vaches qui paraît chez fayard vient
d'être publié sainte croix des vaches
c'est un un village coupé du monde qui
poursuivent et où pour survivre le maire
a décidé de cultiver de la beuh bio
c'est comme ça vous voulez vous dites de
la beuh bio est donc dans ce troisième
volume la fin des haricots le maire
mafieux donc devient conseiller
d'emmanuel macron pour l'agriculture
dans des manuels macron vous allez un
peu vite on va dire qu'il ressemble à
une manière ressemble comme deux gouttes
d'eau emmanuel macron et comme ils
s'appellent pas autrement
j'en ai conclu que c'était emmanuel
macron alors c'est pas tout à fait
manuel macron c'est évident qu'il ya une
décale que de la réalité
là l'idée en fait c'était effectivement
un village qui est coupée du monde où il
ya des paysans qui ont été obligés
d'avoir une vie parallèle en fait pour
survivre sinon il était absolument cuit
il y avait il ya deux en fait deux
députés qui sont arrivés dans ce village
qui sont un peu qu'ils sont ils vont
presser ça s'est fait dans les deux
précédents dont il ya tout un tas de
péripéties qu'on a sur lequel on voit
pas s'étendre là mais toujours est il
que ce paysan qui est plein de bon sens
et en même temps qui a développé cette
activité parallèle donc avec un
écosystème qui lui est particulier mais
que personne évidemment
évidemment personne ne connaît et encore
moins à l'elysée va se retrouver
propulsé donc au plein coeur ce que
j'appelle le game parce que en fait le
milieu politique m'a toujours beaucoup
internet justement je voulais parce que
c'est l'aspect le plus intéressant de ce
troisième tome
il se trouve qu'à la fin vous remercier
votre éditrice isabelle saporta isabelle
saporta et candidate aux municipales
elle est la femme devienne et de yannick
jadot en plus d'être journaliste et vous
remercier aussi gaspard good food sert
alors je dois dire une chose c'est sûr
isabelle effectivement et mon éditrice
mais elle n'était pas candidate
quand j'ai commencé le 10 mai ça m'a
bien arrangé puisque en fait au fur et à
mesure que j'écrivais le livre j'ai
évidemment jeu
je suis pas du tout lourd sur l'intimité
mais j'avais tout de même des échos de
la manière dont elle se présentait elle
m'a permis de rencontrer gaspard ganzer
qui a tout de même été au coeur du lycée
j'ai conseillé relations presse de
françois legault a égalisé donc lui il
était vraiment dans le game comme vous
dites au dernier niveau il était au
dernier niveau donc oui mimi m'a raconté
non non pas du tout des secrets
politiques mais par contre moi ce qui
m'intéressait plus des choses l'ambiance
des petites ce que je trouve incroyable
c'est ces gens qui sont projetés dans
cette pièce de théâtre qui qui qui
paraît complètement fou quand on quand
on lit l'air de l'extérieur et ce
théâtre et qui allait en même temps le
peuple et de mensonges parce que de
mensonges en tout cas de ces espèces de
de fake en permanence insiste beaucoup
là dessus dans le livre histoire
d'éléments de langage dès qu'il ya un
truc qui font produire des éléments de
langage s'est essayé de retranscrire une
réalité qui est pas vraiment la réalité
mais l'articulant différemment pour
essayer d'arranger les choses et donc
cesser si l'on vous le dépeignez d'une
façon très originale est toujours avec
la fausse naïveté qui me caractérise
l'auteur gravats sans aval heck
donc pour vous la politique c'est le
game et le game je trouve est une assez
bonne invention est un bon concept pour
comprendre la politique d'aujourd'hui au
dernier niveau justement il ya un game
au niveau local mais il ya un game au
niveau national puis un game au niveau
international et et quand on appartient
au cercle restreint des gates des gamers
du dernier niveau
c'est quand on est à l'elysée justement
quand on est à bélisaire ce que un des
premiers trucs m'a raconté hier il m'a
dit quand on arrive là bas qu'est qui
conçoit on pète un câble je dis rien
espèce de truc qui vous saisit qui vous
monte à la tête vous vous avez
l'impression de ne plus faire partie du
monde et donc pour pour revenir à ça moi
ce qui me fascine c'est ce mélange de
deux d'éléments de langage de fausseté
de discours un peu tout fait et d'impact
sur la réalité qui est qui et où même
prégnant puisque évidemment les
politiques ont un impact direct sur le
monde convient sur notre quotidien
donc je manque d'ailleurs je suis pas
sûr après avoir lu votre livre on n'est
pas sûr qu'il avait dans un pack
d'ailleurs favori oui c'est ce qui anime
le game dites-vous sait on appelle ça la
machine ce dernier niveau on est en
prise directe avec la machine
mais ce qui anime la machine c'est le
mystère on sait pas très bien
dépassent effectivement c'est ça que je
vais dire à mes personnages et c'est ça
que je alors à tort ou à raison je
connais pas suffisamment j'ai enfin
n'ayant pas été président de la
république moi même je peux
difficilement le savoir mais c'est en
tout cas ça que je ressens c'est à dire
un espèce de tourbillon dans lequel les
gens sont pris qui sait il ya cette
phrase de cocteau la cie de ses mystères
nous dépassent feignons d'en être les
organisateurs tout à fait c'est
exactement ça et je pense que quand on
est un homme politique à ce niveau là on
s d'une part je pense qu'on a un peu
saisis de vertige qu'on essaye de courir
après le après cette espèce de mouvement
perpétuel
il ya tourbillon un tourbillon au surf
la vague mais où on court après mai mais
toute façon on n'a pas d'impact sur la
vague
c'est ça surtout clic et combien voit
bien avec vos gamers comme vous le bon
c'est ça alors du coup moi j'essaie
propulsé là dedans mon personnage qui
effectivement terriens qui en même s'il
a son écosystème de petites magouilles
de trafiquants de drogue enfin deux
bleus en tout cas pour faire vivre son
village il arrive là dedans avec son
espèce de bon sens et un truc alors la
géorgie 1 j invente une anecdote qui
n'est pas tout à fait arrivée mais qui
arrivait juste avant que le livre centre
c'est à dire qui est des agriculteurs se
révoltent et monte sur paris avec leurs
tracteurs mais d'énormes tracteur un
circuit rien pour les arrêter on peut à
moins de 2 des tarifs et récemment c'est
arrivé mais là je me suis pas possible
que ça arrive avant la sortie du livre
je m'excusais ce commentaire cette
remarque égoïsme et il était en train de
monter à paris se sont arrêtés un peu
avant mais donc là dans mon livre ils
font si défonce les péages et on peut
rien faire à part mettre une bombe est
donc ce que comment dire mon héros va à
leur rencontre avec un énorme tracteur
les stops effet un espèce de pauvres
c'est un truc tout simple tout le monde
s'assoit en cercle et tout le monde se
met à parler évidemment le soufflé
retombe et grâce à sahorre tout on est
épaté parce que tout le monde dit mme tu
as une chance de cocu c'est la chance du
débutant
tu es allé pour négocier dans ce truc et
qui allait s'embraser et a réussi à
désamorcer la bombe
et ça je comprends pas pourquoi on le
fait pas c'est alors c'est juste être
d'une naïveté crasse je laisse
comprendre à apporter des réponses et
parfois on a parlé hier de réponse
pourquoi j'ai engagé en tant que citoyen
là ça dépasse germond cadre d'écrivains
pourquoi on a pas d un plaisir il ne
dira voilà c'est compliqué c'est un fait
exactement comme le problème des animaux
on mange des animaux moutons n'a pas
envie de manger parce qu'on a évolué
mais c'est compliqué il ya en fait ya
pas vraiment de solution qu'est ce qu'on
fait au lieu de ça on est toujours non
d'autres qu'on essaie de mentir un peu
d'arranger les choses de 2 est
constamment de se disputer ce que je
sais maintenant de ce que j'ai des échos
par donc mon éditrice gaspard candeur
quelques personnes comme ça que j'ai
côtoyés chez moi j'ai tendance à penser
qu'on vit dans une petite cicatrice en
fait un vrai réellement mais pour de bon
or ça me le confirme je veux dire
malheureusement et que au plus haut
niveau
sap a l'air de bien marcher là dedans
quoi je dirais un début d'explication
parce que c'est vrai qu'on est on se les
poser d'ailleurs à la dernière élection
présidentielle où il y avait tellement
de candidats
c'est pourquoi tous ces gens ont envie
d'être président de la république alors
que ça n'apporte rien ça permet pas de
s'enrichir
on n'a que des ennuis tout le monde vous
déteste au bout de 15 jours et avec
emmanuel macron ça n'a pas loupé et vous
de vous donner une explication du dico
pourquoi elle se jette ton dans la
politique au mépris de sa santé de son
honneur de sa famille en étendant le
cercle on espère toucher à la vérité en
faisant corps avec la folie en la
servent en s'identifiant à elle même si
on ne la contrôle pas on a l'impression
fait corps avec cette espèce de voile a
en tout cas c'est une hypothèse
c'était très rationnelle à au moins une
explication parce que justement gaspard
grande soeur m'a raconté je ne sais pas
s'il en parle dans ses livres par
exemple quand il était conseiller de 2,2
hollande
ils vont aux 24 heures du mans il
s'assoit dans la tribune dont le speaker
10 et voilà monsieur hollande nous fait
l'honneur
il y avait une tribune en face avec
plein de public tout le monde se lève et
les siffler pendant 10 minutes quoi une
autre où ils vont au sens de
l'agriculture il paraît qu'on s'y
étaient recouverts de crachats quoi ils
ont l'impression d'être touché 2 mai
donc il ya bien il ya bien une
explication je dirais les gens sont pas
masochistes c'est toujours le doucher la
vérité cette question au coeur de celle
initiée à quelque chose où l'abbé les
avez les doigts dans une prise
électrique et nous pas bas en tout cas
vouloir souhaité pour en savoir plus sur
la politique actuelle
donc se pencher sur le troisième tome de
la saga sainte-croix des vaches de
vincent ravalec ça s'appelle la fin des
haricots c'est paru chez fayard et je
signale aussi la parution de l'intégrale
de vos nouvelles vous êtes un très grand
ça j'en suis très fier auteur de
nouvelles voilà elles viennent d'être
toutes rassemblées aux éditions au
diable vauvert 1800 pages 1800 pages
toutes les nouvelles de vincent ravalec
[Musique]
martin de la laugh la 230e édition du
salon des artistes français a commencé
au grand palais cette durera jusqu'à
dimanche prochain le 16 février inclus 1
le salon des artistes français ça existe
depuis 1880 c'est une institution
ça a succédé au salon de l'académie des
beaux-arts
alors c'était du temps au 19e siècle
mais ça faisait trois siècles déjà que
ça existe net
et alors là tous les grands scandales
qu'on disait le scandale du salon 2863
c'était au salon de l'académie des
beaux-arts
quand olympiades man et oui le nouveau
le réalisme de courbet et c'est toujours
au salon
quand on disait le salon c'était le
salon qu'est ce qu'elle est comme
différence dès l'instant où on crée le
salon des artistes français c'est que ça
n'est plus l'académie qui décide ce sont
les artistes
d'ailleurs vous êtes la présidente vous
êtes une peintre voilà vous même dans
cette très longue histoire
l'académie royale de peinture interrompu
sa vie au moment de la révolution
française
elle a donc changé de nom l'arrivée
l'assemblée nationale a repris une
exposition en l'endroit de la liberté et
ça a continué tout au long du xixème
siècle en s'épanouissant de plus en plus
à la fin du 19e siècle jules ferry a
demandé à ce que les artistes se
s'organisent eux mêmes et c'est la
création du salon de la société des
artistes français ce que je veux dire
c'est que ces essais à une ligne
continue d'artistes c'est à dire qu'il
n'y a pas eu de rupture entre dans nos
archives on suit très bien la ligne et
les artistes les noms parce des uns aux
autres comme madame vigée lebrun qui
était à l'académie royale de peinture
est passé ensuite au salon autant
napoléonien et etc
donc si vous voulez c'est une ligne la
baptist continue mais là où il ya la
liste
la ligne n'est pas continue c'est que le
salon au 19e siècle c'était cinq cent
mille visiteurs et ç'a duré deux mois
aujourd'hui c'est trente cinq mille
visiteurs en fin d'année dernière
c'était 35 mille visiteurs et ça dure
cinq jours c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui ça ne se
passe plus dans les salons ça a rythmé
l'histoire de la peinture en france
notamment parce qu'il y avait pas que le
soleil avait le salon d'automne il y
avait le seul le scandale des fauves
c'est le salon d'automne de 1905
donc ça que les salons aujourd'hui c'est
plus les salons pourquoi n'ont-ils s'est
passé il s'est passé
effectivement une rupture avec un
désengagement progressif de l'état parce
que par exemple au 19e siècle napoléon
iii il était omniprésent tout une plage
y ait un il ya eu des achats d'état y
compris les des commandes architecture
donc c'était aussi un salon commerçants
enfin je veux dire il y avait des vraies
sacha sur progressivement ça s'est
effritée ces choses là mais on achète
toujours mais plus au salon on achète
encore au salon lors de la brillante
tout ce qu'on voit là c'est ce qui est
actuellement exposé au salon voilà alors
si vous voulez on achète encore mais là
ce sont ou des particuliers des gars y
viennent y faire leur marché
donc il ya une continuité malgré tout de
la rampe romandie le grand avantage de
ce salon le salon c'est que les artistes
exposent des artistes et donc il ya une
tous les artistes émergents peuvent y
venir
oui on y vient seul au fond n'a pas
besoin de ces besoins d'une galerie qui
vous présente vous venez et vous êtes
accepté ou pas par le jury ça permet de
faire émerger des talents tout neuf
c'est la contre-culture on pourrait dire
parce que c'est quand même à l'écart du
marché des galeries même des tendances
de l'heure actuelle les oeuvres qu'on
voit là à venir chercher un certain
nombre d'artistes quillan plaise ou non
et encore des achats toutes les
tendances sont censés être présenté mais
comme on a une très longue histoire
comme vous le savez ces tendances
évoluent et donc le salon évolue aussi
il ya eu une grande explosion avec les
impressionnistes ses retombées
et puis on voit surgir un autre
mouvement les faux etc etc
donc nous comme nous sommes une très
vieille société
on est relativement philosophe sur 7 sur
ses engouements et 71 en gravant comment
vous appelle son père la sélection sur
quels critères les ya 600 artistes
français et étrangers d'ailleurs il n'ya
pas le dvd franc non et que donc je sais
quoi de jury et qui abat ensuite
remettre des récompenses puisqu'on peut
être médaillé par le salon comme
autrefois
oui comme autrefois comme il ya deux
siècles c'est à dire que le jury est
composé dans chaque section par des gens
qui sont médaillés d'or et qui sont élus
tous les trois ans par les sociétaires
ce qui permet un renouvellement mais les
candidatures sont spontanés c'est de
dire si vous monsieur vous voulez
proposer une heure remplissez votre
dossier et vous envoyer les documents
demandés le jury opère sa sélection sur
ce qu'il voit c'est à dire que prend pas
en considération à cv ou pas et c'était
comme ça déjà il ya il ya 200 oui tout à
fait ça permet le fait de par exemple ne
pas tenir compte d'un dossier d'un cv
d'une histoire permet de faire émerger
des gens sur la qualité de l'oeuvre tout
ça donc on connais pas ce monsieur mais
on a vu ça l on trouve que c'est
formidable on le prend et donc si vous
voulez ça cette fraîcheur que n'ont pas
forcément les galeries qui malgré tout
vendre des noms reconnus ou qui
utilisent les soutiennent ont dit que là
c'est vraiment mais ces recherches
émergents si on veut des pâtes reconnu
ce pas la peine d'aller là on n'en
trouvera pas lassé des gens qui ne sont
pas connus c'est même le principe que
c'est le principe
il ya malgré tout des gens qui ont fait
carrière et qui sont connus parce que si
vous laissez le principe de l'atelier ce
père qui a des d'aider les artistes qui
sont là depuis très longtemps qu'ils
sont fidèles
il ya un esprit d'atelier les plus
jeunes sont encouragés ou critiquer car
comme le disait madness et le terrain
but donc une émulation qui se fait ça
c'est michel pigeon par exemple 7,9 que
je trouve magnifique et très vieux
maintenant et qu'un sculpteur de en
taille directe remarquable et on a des
installations il ya des
oui oui comme il ya toutes sortes
d'oeuvres
on essaye le jury 5 vraiment de
sélectionner le meilleur de chaque nom
dans la 230e édition du salon des
artistes français c'est au grand palais
jusqu'à dimanche inclus la fin des
haricots le troisième et dernier tome de
la saga de vincent ravalec sainte-croix
des vhc chez fayard dream bitches le
premier ep de nadéah et b qui s'est
sorti chez quoi il donnerait cordes et
la posture antispécistes darjani que la
cgtg et des clés de bruère merci de nous
avoir suivis rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]